shortcut the Torso on my face and the
next thing about 10 minutes later big
gang of screws must be five or six of
them you know just tore into me rubbing
my clothes off rubbed my skin beat me
with buttons you know and then it was
completely naked
and no sooner was I standing there and
they gave I was growled by the ankles
pulled up to the hitch blocks a little
that I know when that door slammed on me
I wouldn't be getting her dad's Hill for
another seven and a half years I've been
naked
first of all I'd like to begin
by saying that our involvement in the
ira is not a crime story that our our
involved in the ira was it was political
motivated by the highest of ideals and
we never benefited or profited from any
way
I joined the IRA well I sort of an
unusual background I I was born in the
United States
I spent some time in the US Marines but
my parents were Irish and I lived in
Ireland for a number of years before I
joined the Marines and uh I just had a
republican sympathy a natural Republican
sympathy partly because I grew up in the
United States which is a republic so I
had that strong Affinity with the whole
concept of a national democracy within
within a republic and uh I felt that the
area were fighting for that at the time
it's not what they ended up with but at
the time I thought that's what we were
fighting for so I willingly joined and I
was very happy to do so and I think
I have to say that the the proudest
thing I ever done was was become an IRA
volunteer I have a different way I was
brought up in Belfast my grandfather
strangely enough was an orange man
which in case anybody does know they're
like close Clan you know and I'm from a
republican family so it's very
contradictory yeah my family are
Republicans but I was never really
politely aware I was never really
interested you know motion isn't going
to Tesco's but uh two things made me
change my whole outlook despite my
brothers my father being Republicans but
when I was uh 16 my broad brought me to
diary
and it was a time a bloody Sunday I'll
ever get it when I heard all the
gunshots and all the people who have
murdered 14 and rewarded by British bar
Troopers
started to change my whole idea of where
I was living
it was dominated by unionist and had
been a bit about a British at the time
you know
and shortly after that my school admit
Jim Carr is only 16 years of age he was
murdered by loyalists she had a number
of times in the head and face
just for being a Catholic adult to
events really
steered me towards a republican movement
the actual IRAs it became known today
was really after the 1916 raising they
became Oakland or the Irish Republican
Army
in 1969 they split into the official Ira
which was more a socialist you know uh
former student group The stickies and or
the provisional Ira of which we remember
you and me were members of the revision
Library which were more militant
organization at the time devoted to uh
you know the total overthrow of British
rule in Ireland see Ireland uh was
always treated by England as one country
when the British talk about the four
nations of the UK
they never say the five nations they
never say
England Scotland Wales and the two
nations in Ireland the only British rule
we were one nation but as soon as we
started talking about independent
Ireland we're suddenly two Nations
nationalists and unions
in 1969 I think it was it just the Civil
Rights exploded into uh you know the uh
to the arm campaign that eventually
became by the provisional IRA and again
you know it's very important to
emphasize that the vast majority of
nationalists didn't support the IRA just
like the vast majority of nationalists
in any country don't support armed
groups because it's too dangerous to do
so
basically myself
I was there at the time to protect nice
and serious against the onslaught of
loyalism in our ears were getting houses
we're getting bombed getting burned to
the ground you know so facing at the
start is more to protect narcissists but
as a British started to bring in more
troops more armor then we just we knew
that we'll have to step up our sales on
their defense of what we were going to
do you know it was only for maybe a
couple of years before I started to
actually do some training down south so
it'll come back up to the north to face
the British but it was very very basic
there was not an awful lot of thought
going on by hand except maybe just
learned how to shoot something go back
up the North and fire riff or whatever
you know when I joined I mean I was you
know I was active at different things I
at one stage I was I was approached and
I was told to go to America to buy
weapons because I had an American accent
and I thought that was ridiculous
because I had been an instructor in a
special operations unit in the US
Marines and I thought I had a lot more
to offer the IRA than my accent but no I
was sent over there to Boston I mean it
was ridiculous because I mean we only
needed about 3 four different types of
weapons and anybody could have done it
we had loads of guys their American
accents so I know for some reason the
Impressions somebody was trying to get
rid of me for some reason that I went
over there and at that stage uh I met
the infamous lady Bulger uh he was uh
you know a South Boston gangster but I
was introduced to him by Irish Americans
who knew I needed false licenses and
weapons and things like that and you
know law abiding citizens can get you
that stuff so uh they introduced me to
him now I had no idea who he was I
wasn't from Boston I never heard of Jim
Bulger by the way you never called him
Whitey to his face
so sometimes it's hard for me to um
disentangle myself from
uh the Jim Bulger I first met knowing
nothing about him and and the weighty
Bulger I know about now I mean this guy
wasn't snatching handbags up grannies on
the street I mean this was a very
capable criminal and very very capable
guy you know and uh dude never found
Australians at the area in the rear at
least you more if you're training that
you had the Marines that you could uh
teach ARA volunteers a lot that you
learn well you see at the time when I
when I joined the IRA I didn't think the
area I joined the US Marines to enhance
my professional development and you know
and also to test my commitment I knew if
I went back and joined the Marines and I
came back and joined the IRA then I was
serious about joining the IRA
I never for a moment uh was presumptuous
enough to believe the irony needed my
help because I really honestly believed
that the IRA was as highly trained
professional organization I kept hearing
about yeah but I realized later I kept
hearing about it from the British the
British kept saying we're this highly
trained how do you think you know
organization the most deadly gorilla
organization in the world certainly when
I joined it and I seen you know uh some
of the training was was farcical and
some of it was wrong and there was no
training that I ever saw like in in
military tactics nothing like that
well for me the scariest was being in
the founder of my comrades going into
the city center or bulbs and machine
codes because when we were stopped we
saw we're going to be shut down by this
true of British soldiers they were doing
a foot patrol and they all had their
rifles SLR rifles M Dallas
and we thought well my thought my head
was if I don't fit and get away I'm
going to be shut down here and we're
just going to say well we we pulled our
weapons first and they're going on
borders so I thought better take a
chance and see what happens here and
that's when we also started fading
because they calls between us the
British soldiers lasted for about five
months but every one of his Minds to get
away a day you know well a few scary
moments I mean it's hard it's hard to
pinpoint anything in particular uh I
remember we hit a hurricane coming over
uh on the Valhalla the American fishing
boat that brought us the guns across and
we hit a substantial hurricane that
Captain Anderson who was the captain of
the boat
said in 25 years fish in the North
Atlantic it's the worst storm he'd ever
seen we barely survived it I didn't
think we were going to make it how much
Robin's important well seven and a half
tons of weapons but you know it wouldn't
have made any difference to every
campaign it was just standard stuff you
know it was it was like a trial run and
there was there there were scary moments
too you know and you know an act of
service so you know helicopters and copy
and thinking you're caught and things
like that it's it's hard to put on down
but for me the scariest thing would have
been to think that we were doing this
for nothing
you know the scariest thing would have
been the thought that we were we would
be doing this and wouldn't achieve our
goal of an online Republic you know and
then the scary thoughts too of things we
learned in hindsight about how
infiltrated we were yes the head of Ira
security
was a British Vegas
the British intelligence Services were
allowing informers to kill informers
exactly I mean the skullduggery and of
the Dirty War was was just unbelievable
the story of it they haven't even
scratched the circle telling the story
of what went on there incredible
incredible
I would never have joined an
organization that the Liberty targeted
civilians I mean that that's just not
who I am you know I joined the IRA with
the highest ideals and the greatest
personal risk to fight for the full
freedom of my country and I wanted to
fight British Military and their
constabury things happened atrocities
happened you know civilians were killed
uh it was uh never intentional that's no
Comfort to the families of those victims
uh the IRA had to be careful and they
you know not to do things that were
morally wrong the overwhelming majority
of our volunteers were never involved in
operation that killed the civilian what
was sudden also forgot that the British
newness were involved in plenty of
bombings but of course yeah
I mean British Military Intelligence was
directly involved the biggest moment
never worried about it did you ever hear
that they never hear the British media
asking you what do you think all the
informs that the British did or the
unionists did but again you know we
don't want to get into what about Trier
you know I know that but I'm just saying
you know uh I I do know I I meant they
were involved in things that went wrong
and it destroyed their lives the guilt
they know they suffered guilt they were
cold-hearted monsters but again this you
know it's a hard thing to talk about
because it's no Comfort anything
in fact exactly it adds insulin look at
it if so if Obama often killed him a
member of my family yeah and the bomber
said well we didn't mean to do it
yeah so it's one of these conundrums
it's impossible to answer there's no
there's no there's no right answer all
you can say is from the bottom of your
heart you wish it hadn't happened but
none of this would have happened if the
British government stayed
the [__] out of Ireland yeah
the arms thing I was involved in was
betrayed men and former I saw it I we
were arrested
that's a world exclusive I'm telling you
yeah and uh we um
so we were caught by the Irish Navy off
the coast of Kerry but uh I've recently
believed that the British were
overseeing the whole operation I saw a
British Nimrod reconnaissance aircraft
earlier that day I was charged with
possession of arms and explosives
uh with intent to endanger life or with
to enable others to endanger life and I
got 10 years for that well I got 10
years for that but I actually got
another three years for an attempted
Escape in uh in November 1985 we were on
a very professionally organized Escape
uh we had to get to 14 Gates we got
through 13 and the explosive charge
replaced in the landscape difficult
didn't go I know so we were very close
to getting out but we got an extra three
years for that so the last time I was in
England when I was I was repatriated
Ireland we were flown from I think full
salt in prison to to what year was that
what year were you in London I was
arrested in London in 1996. and this is
the first time you're back in London
yeah yeah yeah I was arrested along with
five comrades one Sunday morning and
near the place where I live in new Lodge
Road and we were caught by a British Paw
Patrol and we had a lot of bombs machine
guns City Center to do a lot of damage
not going to say well it was but we
intended to do a lot of damage
unfortunately we were stopped by British
football told who were tipped off
by an Informer again
and there was a bit of thirsty culture
we jumped out of van and we started
fighting on to Han with these British
troops fortunately we got away
and there was a big God made a terrible
search operation Holly cobblers all this
here and I we all got away but I was uh
recaptured about three months later
doing another military operation and
that's I ended up until for 10 years in
the notorious hitch blocks how were you
treated by prison officers what were
other inmates like other people in
prison well I have to say no I was in
the South uh of Ireland in a prison and
uh it wasn't that bad we had strip
searching things like that but it just
wasn't as systematically uh bad it was a
bad prison and it was you know but we
didn't get the torture that Sam and the
boys would have got uh when I was in
jail in England uh I was in the special
secure units in belmarsh and that at the
start and it was a prison within a
prison and it was it was it was just um
it was sort of like a regime nearly
where they'd have to you know mail you
in daylight and an envelope and an
envelope because
um it was a concrete tomb within a
concrete tomb yeah well the plank that I
started off one of the first early black
men what happened was I just introduced
the Marcus thoughts or builti's special
prisons called the hits blocks she got
the idea from the Nazis these were to
put in the Jews the Quicken up the
extermination of the Jews so you got the
idea for them she always says they were
escape proof you know but firstnet I
went under reception I was asked to put
on Prison uniform I told him and I put
on I'm not a criminal a political
prisoner shortcut the doors down my face
and the next thing about 10 minutes
later big gang of screws must be five or
six of them you know just tore into me
rubbing my clothes off rubbed my skin
beat me with buttons you know and then
it was completely naked
and no sooner was I standing there I was
growled by the ankles
pulled up to the hitch blocks by the
idols these screws and his plugs is
quite a horrendous place I mean it's a
neighbor you're going up or pitch dark
knight and you just see this big ship
like a hitch it just comes into your
your vision you know and you've already
heard these terrible stories about this
place you know so as soon as I got into
a circle the screws were written there
are no our party screws that beat me
along the governor and he's witnessed
and all this here you know that the
pigeons probably just lost 10 minutes
but it felt like ours because it does
kicking in batting in a little blue was
pointing at me everywhere you know then
after beating the drag me down to the
hits blocks turned into a cell a little
that I know when that door slammed on me
I wouldn't be getting her that silver
nor seven and a half years I've been
naked and I didn't realize a horror that
was going to be visited upon me by the
screws there were statistics screws and
you were going to get beat every day and
that's just a slum you're getting beat
with the buttons in the boots every
single day so it was a total neighboring
hi I didn't go mad hello you know it's
filmed me you know because the cruelty
and the statisticness of it you know
there were war criminals that got away
with war crimes against naked political
prisoners but once again
it's a well sort of get away with sort
of announces had it been in Russia been
World Airlines
but the British press of course being
who they are you know just suppressed it
went along with British government
Fletcher the Irish press surprise
they're pretty good too but you do
expect your own young people necess like
to throw away Halo what's happening to
you try and help but unfortunately I
wasn't a cave and I used to think about
these men I call a man I'm going to call
them in you know they're scumbags but
these men went home to their wives and
their kids and sat down and had a meal
and had a nice conversation and when we
were soldiers in a war and you know and
you know when you're a soldier in the
war you have to do violent things but
personally speaking
I couldn't even imagine torturing
somebody I mean it just would not you
know I just I just for not for no reason
for no nothing would I torture him on
this just doesn't count in fact
occasionally this is happening ideally
and I just can't get over these guys
doing this but then again most of them
Arrangement they they were your
bitterest political enemies
too you know almost loyalists or orange
men or you know and of course too I
think one of the the bravest thing about
the blanket men and that is that you
know you lost a lot of remission so you
were adding years to your sentence as
well every day you refuse to work you
lost it there yeah so you're doubling
you're you're doubling the time I've
already given you another thing you
could have clicked your fingers and come
off it you'll come off at night time
you've got early release got all the
Comforts of whatever they offered
because you never had anything yeah no
clothes no books no nothing no visits no
letters no nothing and you did it
overwhelmingly to be treated as
political prisoners in a political
conflict in your own country
proud to be Republican I still am and
you know I haven't been cured I'm still
a republican yeah yeah if you kind of
have to now would you go to Ira again
would you would you do all of that over
again on a hard pit ever goes through
what I went through the hitch blocks
people always say to me like some I was
a nightmare
no regrets for anything I did for the
freedom struggle of iron no regrets
whatsoever well I'd be the same in that
I have absolutely no regrets for what
I'd done but if I if I knew what way
would it end up would have joined the
IRA absolutely not I would not have
joined the IRA for an internal
settlement on British terms uh to me it
was total waste of life and uh a total
waste of uh
you know we put up a tremendous
resistance and that was all that was all
squandered uh for political Capital you
know to build the the careers of a
self-reparating click that ran the
movement but having said that looking
back I have no regrets uh for anything I
was involved in
get LED through this pet shop right I
mean really it just looked like I had a
couple of after animals in it you know
what I mean it was a really sorry sight
led up the stairs at the back go in
there shaving-headed monster sitting
behind a table with his nine mil right
and that's the opening Gambit that's how
we're going to start the conversation